سبقت اوكرانيا زياره المسؤولين الاوروبيين
الى كييف لعقد قمه الاتحاد غدا الجمعه
بتحسين صورتها ومحاوله الاسراع في اغلاق
ملفات فضائح الفساد في البلاد فشلت
السلطات حمله واسعه لمكافحه الفساد واكد
مدير مكتب التحقيقات الحكوميه ان هذه
الحمله التي تضمنت اقالات لمسؤولين رفيعي
المستوى هي مجرد البدايه تحركات تاتي تحت
بند هدفين رئيسيين كما يرى محللون الاول
الحفاظ على الدعم الدولي لاوكرانيا
والثاني هو تعزيز محاوله الاوكرانيين
للحصول على العضويه الكامله في الاتحاد
الاوروبي لكن يبدو انها بالفعل المجرد
البدايه فنحن نتحدث عن قضايا فساد ضخمه
وطويله الامد على ما يبدو في اوكرانيا
وعدد كبير من المسؤولين متورطون فيها
فاليوم قضت محكمه اوكرانيه بحبس نائب وزير
الدفاع السابق على ذمه تحقيق فساد في
مشتريات عسكريه
وكانت وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه نشرت
لقطات لعمليه تفتيش في منزل نائب وزير
الدفاع السابق في البلاد حيث تم العثور
اثناء عمليات البحث عن مبلغ كبير من المال
مخزنا في الاريكه
[موسيقى]
هذا الكثير من الملل كما اعلنت الحكومه
الاوكرانيه هذا الاسبوع اقاله مسؤولين
كبار على خلفيه قضيه فساد تتعلق بعمليه
شراء امدادات للجيش باسعار مبالغ فيها
بالاضافه الى قضايا اختلاس في اكبر شركات
استخراج وتكرير النفط واتهامات بالفساد
لرئيس وزاره الدفاع بعمليات شراء سطرات
واقيه للجنود وكانت هذه السترات دون
المستوى وخلال حمله المداهمات حققت
السلطات مع رئيس مصلحه الضرائب في كيف
الذي يزعم انه كان جزءا من مخطط للتغاضي
او يزعم انه كان جزءا للتغاضي عن مليار و
200 الف دولار امريكي من الضرائب غير
المسربه علما انه في منزل رئيس مصلحه
الضرائب عطر من قبل عثر مكتبه تحقيقات
الحكوميه الاوكرانيه عثر على مئات الالاف
من الدولارات ايضا المخباه وساعات وسيارات
فاخره